de Haren pardon Harry et Megane je vous
avais que ça arrive sur Netflix regarder
le récap et puis derrière on a un
spécialiste pour en parler merci Jean-Mi
[Applaudissements]
nous aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est Thomas donc Thomas qui bosse à
point de vue donc ça c'est le teaser en
fait ce qu'on appelle la bande-annonce
de ce qu'on va voir bientôt sur Netflix
ou est-ce que vous l'avez vu vous non
personne personne
j'espère que meganer ils l'ont vu quand
même
quand on a la bande-annoncière enfin on
découvre les premières images de ce truc
qui qu'on attend depuis septembre 2020
mais le truc c'est au-delà du fait qu'il
y a des images qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent
dire de plus que ce qu'ils avaient déjà
dit en fait chez Oprah est racisme de
tout ça c'était 90 minutes il y a 6
épisodes donc on se demande tout ce
qu'il va y avoir les images sont dingues
enfin il y a des images très très fortes
il y a des images de bonheur bien sûr on
sent que Netflix a pas payé des millions
de dollars pour entendre juste on s'aime
on est heureux on est d'accord on va y
avoir quelque chose qu'est-ce qui est
exactement personne ne le sait et
surtout est-ce qu'ils ont voulu modifier
leurs propos suite à la mort de la reine
et à l’accession au trône de Charles III
toute la question c'est de savoir à quel
point ça peut être dommageable pour la
monarchie pour Charles III en fait le
mois de décembre chez Windsor je sais
pas si vous avez votre popcorn mais ça
va être dingue si vous avez fini the
crown ou si vous avez pas fini fini le
parce que là ça va être le nouveau the
crown et le 10 janvier en plus il y a
les mémoires d'Harry donc je pense que
Noël va pas être terrible à son game
cette année mais est-ce que je trouve
comme assez fascinant c'est que des gens
comme vous Bertrand neckerde enfin la
reine fallait à l'époque où Charles III
casse une telle une tasse vous le savez
dans les 5 minutes mais ce qu'il y a
dans ce documentaire les vrais
révélations vous ne savez pas non et en
plus il y a eu beaucoup de pistes
pendant un moment nous a dit ça va être
sur les Invictus Game vous savez ces
jeux qu'organise Harry on nous a dit non
ce sera pas privé il y a la première
réalisatrice qui a été virée parce
qu'elle voulait faire soi-disant selon
les informateurs quelque chose de plus
privé néanmoins là on sent quand même
aussi qu'il y a quand même des images il
va y avoir des choses privées sur
l'histoire d'amour donc il y a tous
cette petite musique et cette petite
rumeurs sans qu'on sache vraiment
forcément l'enjeu est énorme l'enjeu
financier est énorme oui on sait pas
c'est vrai je cette terrible d'être
invité je suis désolé je c'est pas du
tout et ça rajoute encore du piquant
parce que forcément on imagine le
meilleur mais surtout le pire on essaie
de comprendre qu'est-ce que risque la
famille royale on a peut-être une
anecdote aussi une anecdote d'un être à
ça à ce propos tout à fait j'ai regardé
ce matin sur MSNBC les night lignes news
de store hallt donc vraiment des grosses
news machin etc et ce qui se passe ce
que ce que j'ai vu j'étais complètement
accroché c'est que la il y a une
anecdote il y a un énorme scandale en ce
moment en Angleterre tous les journaux
anglais en parlent dans la presse de ce
matin c'est qu'il y a une une dame là
pour l'instant on parlait de la
bande-annonce de de Harry et Meghan sa
sœur sur Netflix à bande annonce vient
de sortir je crois même que pendant que
le teaser ce qu'on appelle le teaser
sortait qui a été William eux étaient
dans l'avion oui c'est ça qui était avec
le timing c'est qu'on se dit quand même
il y a une guerre entre ces deux couples
c'est vraiment on est d'accord c'est
difficile de dire en fait c'est un peu
la stratégie de la revanche Grace je
vous rappelle à la robe de la revanche
de Diana oui Charles avait un programme
télé et ce soir-là elle va à la galerie
serpentine elle porte une incroyable
superbe robe noire et on parle que de la
robe et maintenant vous avez William et
Kate qui vont aux États-Unis pour trois
jours de déplacement un Grand Prix sur
l'environnement bref c'est leur moment
et paf dans l'avion leur balance le
teaser de Ariane sur Netflix c'est vrai
que Williams tout le monde ne parle que
c'est William était persuadé quand il a
vu son frère que son frère avait un
micro alors c'est ce qu'il se dit c'est
ce qui n'a pas aidé
réconciliation familiale c'est que
aujourd'hui la famille royale a peur que
quand Megan est arrivé barque moi il
viennent pas souvent de Californie comme
meilleur en Californie que à Londres
mais qui viennent alors non pas avec des
caméras mais est-ce que leurs propos les
propos échanger dans l'intimité peuvent
pas venir nourrir aussi bien une
autobiographie le film bien sûr livre
aussi bien un documentaire ça aide pas
imaginez si vous avez une cousine que
vous n'aimez pas ou quelqu'un et que
vous dites bah elle va aller baver en
Suisse je vois très bien
alors donc Natacha nous disait que ce
matin parce que vous écoutez la radio
américaine la télévision la télévision
américaine vous avez entendu qui est un
scandale autour de ça c'était quoi alors
voilà ça on peut rebondir ou en tout cas
avec ça
n'avait parlé donc devant Oprah Winfrey
de soupçons de façons
de racisme et là du coup ce matin je
regarde de les news et
donc les storesannonce que on y a une
interview d'une dame c'est une dame qui
est noire elle a des très jolies
dreadlocks etc bref et elle dit voilà
j'étais à une soirée tout dernièrement
où la la donc la maman de Kate donc la
future reine croissance c'est la
marraine de Harry qui s'appelle Suzanne
Eco ah je pensais que c'était la maman
donc
de William très bien c'est avancé vers
cette dame
donc c'est un grand Galam à machin Bazin
il a écarté sans lui adresser la parole
elle lui a balancé comme ça de d'un coup
de la main elle lui a balancé toutes les
dreadlocks à l'arrière et pour vérifier
qu'elle avait bien un pin's enfin un
badge comme quoi le côté un peu thé noir
dont tu es pas invité c'est un bon idée
premier deux Jo la
premièrement deuxièmement
et donc deuxièmement elle lui dit comme
ça donc elle vérifie louloute était
évidemment estomaqué et elle lui dit
mais vous êtes de quel pays vous venez
et là elle dit mais moi je viens de
d'Angleterre je suis britannique non non
mais vraiment votre pays c'est c'est
lequel
tu aurais vraiment
cette anecdote est réelle c'est une
réception qui a lieu à Buckingham mardi
dernier Camila réunis de la reine des
Belges la reine de Jordanie 300
personnes et en effet il y a cette
responsable d'association qui a eu un
échange très désagréable et raciste avec
cette dame qui est cette dame cette dame
s'appelle Lady EC alors elle est l'une
des marraines du prince William en fait
c'était les anciennes dames de compagnie
de la reine et accompagné même depuis la
mort d'Elizabeth II on s'est dit
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire c'est dame de
compagnie qui est ferveur elle a 83 ans
et on s'est dit avec quelle bonne idée
on va les garder comme dame du palais
elles aideront ils donneront un petit
coup de main pour les événements c'est
la pire idée qui soit parce qu'en effet
cette dame a eu un échange absolument
inacceptable avec cette responsable
d'association et là c'est ça qui est
très nouveau avec Charles III et Kamila
c'est que autant d'Elisabeth II on
aurait certainement attendu machin en
deux heures on a dit c'est terminé effet
immédiat elle part et le porte-parole de
William a dit le racisme n'a pas sa
place dans la société et là on rebondit
dans nos deux histoires c'est que ça
arrive aussi au pire moment au moment où
William et Kate sont dans l'avion et
qu'aux États-Unis on plaisante pas avec
le racisme encore moins qu'en Angleterre
il y a eu l'opéra là maintenant il y a
ce documentaire il y a un bouquin qui va
sortir aussi la bio de Harry il y a un
moment aussi oui
on peut rappeler aussi qu'il y a quand
même on parle d'un contrat à 150
millions de dollars avec Netflix avec
ces deux-là donc je pense que c'est pas
juste pour qu'on les voit en train de
beurrer leur tartine le matin je pense
qu'il y a une vraie exigence toute ma
famille
[Rires]
tous les insignes bien sûr britanniques
etc donc il a vu tout ça on sait dans la
dans sa bio on sait très bien qu'il y
aura des trucs très lourds et ils ont à
mon avis ils ont de quoi trembler parce
que voilà il va y avoir ils vont revenir
essentiellement beaucoup c'est ce qui se
dit sur leur départ en Californie et sur
les raisons de leur départ
de bombe quoi ça va être vraiment énorme
je pense que non il y a des histoires
qu'on connaît pas forcément on va
découvrir des trucs pourquoi se font
barrer comment s'est passé en fait nous
ce qu'on veut savoir c'est pourquoi
elles se sont brouillés les deux
ensemble Mégane et Kate pourquoi elles
peuvent pas se blairer il va y avoir du
crépage de chignon des trucs ça va être
génial non mais là les images sont
dingues c'est une réalisation de dingue
Netflix ça va être une phrase évidemment
la vérité souvent au bout du couloir
mais la vérité est souvent au centre
mais en gros si il va y avoir un
coupable c'est la monarchie britannique
ou c'est Mégane c'est dur de me demander
ça on est en train de dépoussiérer tout
ça ou est-ce que vous pensez au
contraire que Logan malgré tout en
affaires du mal moi je pense que Mégane
est quelqu'un de formidable et sincère
et quand elle parle de race
on peut débattre comme sur ce plateau il
y a aussi différents avis sur le point
de vue et mais c'est vrai que d'une
certaine manière même si c'est forcé
typiquement sur le racisme la dame dont
on parlait la dame de compagnie 83 ans
elle aurait pas été licenciée en deux
heures si Mégane c'était pas si touchy
donc on l'aime ou qu'on la déteste elle
apporte un vent de très cher même si
aujourd'hui ils sont out ils sont plus
dans la famille royale la porte quelque
chose et moi je pense que c'est une
femme qui a beaucoup apporté c'est
dommage que les cheveux plus réellement
qu'elle soit pue au sein de la monarchie
mais oui c'est elle
en interne en tous les cas je ramène je
rappelle votre livre s'appelle Altesse
en détresse merci beaucoup c'est
toujours un plaisir